brandon you're talking about the ferrari
crash do you want to go with that one
first
sure all right ferrari
dude this guy had a f-40 and crashed
into the [ __ ] tree
it's a two-point do i what's what to say
i didn't read dark i saw the headline
chin
so it says it's on australia i think
it's 2.3 million dollar ferrari f40
well that's does it say if he was
drinking or he just [ __ ]
he just bought it yeah there's not much
uh info on the sky
there's two people driving apparently
they're fine or two people in the car
the driver lost control and they're both
fine no injuries but the car
is just see 2.3 million what do you do
in this situation is this car
salvageable no no one's gonna no dude
it's over it's over
you do i mean [ __ ] man 2.3 million
dollars
yeah there's not many of them so where
the [ __ ] so where are you going to get
the parts you send it to the goddamn
factory
oh god and you have one of the greatest
cars of all time
2.3 million dollars how bad is the
damage
it's not good it's total look at that
that car is done it looks a little
wobbly but
2.3 million dollars fix it right now
those cars
like the gt carreras the porsches you
know they're both collectors they don't
have abs braking or
they don't have you know power lock rate
so it's like these guys probably used to
drive in the newer ferraris or whatever
they get in that thing and they're going
fast and there's no
you know it's problems man big problems
and that's a two point three million
dollar car
it's an old dude it's like in this old
yeah it looks old
super cool it's terrible all right well
too bad
leave it there i'm gonna tell you this
right now yeah yeah yeah yeah
watch your tongue okay what's gonna
happen
what are you gonna do use some of that
boxing you've been doing
oh she was [ __ ] disrespected